- Donald you are gross.
Nobody likes you but you
come back every couple years
and nobody knows why.
You're like the McRib.
(laughing)
- When he graduated college he put
his shoulder to the wheel,
nose to the grindstone,
borrowed six billion
dollars from his father
and started a career.
(laughing)
- But that's all behind him now.
Donald is very happy with his lovely wife,
insert name here.
- Donald and I have a lot in common.
We both live in New York.
We both play golf.
We both fantasize about his daughter.
- I'd say stick to your real estate
but all of your buildings are hideous.
The Taj Mahal in New Jersey is horrible.
There hasn't been a shithole that big
on the shores of New
Jersey since the Situation
took it to the ass from Pauly D.
- You know Donald Trump
is such a douche bag.
That if you look up the word
douche bag in the dictionary
there's a picture of Spencer Pratt.
(laughing)
But if you look close
Spencer Pratt is holding up
a picture of Donald Trump.